you wrote your own movie I wrote my own
menu directed B yes
is that crazy how much time it doesn't
seem like it slowed you down at all but
it would seem to me that takes like a
year and a year and a half of your life
at least it took a year I had an idea
after I got in this fight with my my
family after Thanksgiving about the
election right we really yelling at each
other and about Trump or yelling at some
people of for Trump some are and some
are so I just kind of knew that like the
mood of the country is so angry and
divided and that really comes to play
the most during the week of Thanksgiving
so I was like let me tell a story this
crazy story about this family fighting
during Thanksgiving about politics [ __ ]
you
and then the movie kind of takes this
like crazy turn where like these bad
guys come to the house and start like
beating people it's funny and it's
violent and it's just kind of a movie
that's kind of like making fun of of the
political climate we're in